welcome back to the david pakman show i
am farin cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today
now if you tuned into the program
yesterday you heard producer pat
doing a wonderful job talking about
donald trump going after mitch mcconnell
going after elaine chow and i don't want
to beat a dead horse here but i do want
to take a couple minutes
and talk about that story one more time
because i do believe
that there's more
that we need to be looking at here
so in case you missed the story
yesterday donald trump over the weekend
came out
let me just read it this is what he put
on truth social
why do republican senators allow a
broken down hack politician mitch
mcconnell to openly disparage
hard-working republican candidates for
the united states senate
this is such an affront to honor and to
leadership he should spend more time and
money helping them get elected and less
time helping his crazy wife and family
get rich on china
so of course elaine chao
was donald trump's transportation
secretary and yes there were plenty of
you know allegations against her while
she was transportation secretary that
she was
steering federal money towards her
family business they were going to
investigate that
but then after she resigned after
january 6 the
doj just said ah forget it let bygones
be bygones right um
that's terrible and of course it was
trump's doj but uh that doesn't mean the
doj couldn't still do that right
i mean there were credible allegations
right there was evidence that suggested
that she was using her position to
benefit her family business
kind of sounds like the thing we ought
to be investigating right isn't that the
kind of thing that we want to root out
of politics
but all of that aside
it's the attack on mitch mcconnell
himself
that really stuck out to me
because trump like everybody else in
this country looks at the poll numbers
and right now those poll numbers show
that not only are democrats most likely
going to retain control of the senate
but they're probably going to pick up a
couple of seats too
they could end up picking up seats in
wisconsin
pennsylvania
and ohio
as well as holding on to seats that they
previously thought they may not
including in the state of georgia so
democrats are sitting pretty
republicans
are running out of money
you know thanks to rick scott being a
horrible manager of the national
republican senatorial campaign committee
um
they're running out of money
they're pulling ads in crucial swing
states including wisconsin and
pennsylvania that i just mentioned
and so they need a fall guy
they need somebody to blame for the fact
that republicans in the senate are doing
very bad
inner mitch mcconnell right donald trump
as we all know has been going after
mitch mcconnell for months and months
and months
just absolutely trashing the guy
earlier this year and last year of
course trying to get people to run
for senate by pledging that they will
not vote for mitch mcconnell to be in a
leadership position again
uh he only got two people by the way to
sign on to that whole deal
but this is something trump has been
laying the groundwork for for a year
replacing mitch mcconnell
so what he is doing right now has less
to do with the mcconnell's wife
has nothing to do with the
investigations that should be taking
place
he is setting mcconnell up to take the
fall for the fact
that republicans put forth some bad
candidates
and the irony here of course
is that these candidates
that are likely going to lose
these are all trump-backed candidates
ron johnson in wisconsin latest poll
numbers show him doing terribly right
now
well he's also
implicated in the fake elector scheme
but don't worry he said this week he
came out he's like i was only involved
in it for quote seconds
okay
but you were still involved by your own
admission now so
good luck with that in court
then you have of course dr oz in
pennsylvania we all know how that's
going herschel walker in georgia
terrible campaign with a terrible
candidate j.d vance up in ohio who trump
thought was going to be the golden boy
can't even beat tim ryan
so all of trump's people are failing
and mitch mcconnell has been coming out
recently blaming trump without having to
name him
for basically saddling the republican
party with these horrible candidates
so trump is trying to flip the script of
course
blame it all on mcconnell because his
leadership is just terrible
so he can finally oust the man that he
has had this personal vendetta against
for over a year
probably not going to work
probably
wouldn't work out well for republicans
anyway even if that happened because
as horrible of a human being as i
believe that mitch mcconnell is
he is good at what he does now what he
does is terrible don't get me wrong
but that guy knows how to play the game
that guy knows how to manipulate people
he knows how to be sneaky conniving
backstabbing all of that
that's how he's gotten so far ahead in
life
so if you remove that guy from the top
of your party you're going to suffer
democrats are going to do so much better
so i guess what i'm saying is
keep up the crusade donald
because i would love nothing more than
to see mitch mcconnell ousted from
leadership
because that's going to create a massive
void within the republican party that i
don't think any of you
know how to fill